hey John we have an announcement that's
right it's a special cold open to
announce that over at our patreon
patreon comm slash dear Hank and John
where you can go to directly support
this podcast and also the other things
that complexly does yeah online video
educational projects if you donate at
five dollars a month or more you will
get access to a new secret very brief
podcast called this week in Ryan's
that's right every week a brief five to
ten minute podcast about a different
Ryan every week forever forever there's
a lot of Ryan's John there's people with
the first name Ryan there's people with
a last name Ryan there's places called
Ryan there's things called Ryan and
we're going to talk about all of them
over the course of the next thirty years
of our lives
and it's gonna be available as five
dollar patreon perk at patreon.com slash
to your hanka john and you might be
asking yourself dear fan of the pod do
you really need money to do dear Hank
and John well let me tell you something
no we don't in fact in fact that money
is going to be going into our production
company which is where all of the
patreon money so far has been going
where we use it to do things like
scishow and crash course and healthcare
triage and sexplanations and the
financial diet and a bunch of other
things that we do at our production
company so this is just kind of a way to
help us pay the bills on our other just
it's it's all part of the same family of
content and not all goes into the same
pot where we try and try and make money
to pay for this right we want to make
educational video and we also want to
make this weekend Ryan's and so it lines
up nicely with our interests so if
you're interested please head over to
patreon comment and John thanks
everybody who supported our podcast over
the year and thanks also to everybody
who's about to start listening to this
weekend Ryan's we're very excited about
it we're gonna make this week's this
weekend Ryan available for free at the
end of this podcast so you can get a
sweet sweet taste of the silliness that
is to come
[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
there was that first think of it Dear
John and Hank it's a comedy podcast
where me and that guy he's my brother
John we answer your questions give me
two Bs advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hey John how you doing I'm
doing all right Hank
things are good as you know there's a
little bit of work stress in our lives
right now but other than that I'm great
yeah yeah I was trying to like come up
with a thing to have happen to me this
week but it's all boring and it's all
meetings yeah we're doing or doing the
yearly evaluations of all the people at
the company we're like it's not
evaluation it's just sort of like a
check-in and and so like all the people
who are the people who report to me I
like but let's have our ticket and then
we talked about how the jobs are and how
they like it and how things are going
and it's great but there it's a lot of
people and I'm I like I'm happy that I
do it but then also like it's like oh
that's a new thing to add to the list of
things but yeah I'm not very good Hank
as you know at meetings or check-ins I
kind of designed my life around the idea
that I was never gonna have to go to a
meeting because I find meetings to be a
form of oppression and also when I am in
a meeting my friends and co-workers can
attest to this I like shake somewhat
violently and roll my eyes and mutter to
myself and frequently will whisper
quietly has this meeting reached its
conclusion yeah I just find them to be
extraordinarily inefficient that said I
understand that everyone in the world
but me sees value in meetings so I am
almost definitely wrong except I still
kind of think that I'm right
I mean you are definitely kind of right
there's definitely in efficiencies to
meetings but also there's no other way
for humans to talk to each other about
the things that they have to do than to
schedule it sometimes so my life has
lots of meetings in it John that's
that's who I have become and I I take
most of the bullets for you in terms of
meetings so just a priest
I ain't me I know and I do I deeply
appreciate that I just want to pause and
say Hank thank you for attending so many
meetings on my behalf okay
do you have a short poem for us this
week I don't know I've been in too many
meetings I haven't even read any poetry
this week it's a darkness oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay well goodbye yellow brick
road where the dogs of society howl you
can't plant me in your penthouse I'm
going back to my plow that's by Elton
John that's a good one
we should have you do this every week
should we answer some questions from our
listeners okay this one's from Alison
that's a really good often John Lincoln
shop sensitive Alison who hath we killed
it it's like man that meeting
conversation was hilarious
Alison asks dear Hank and John I'm
always confused of how to respond when
someone compliments the outfit I'm
wearing if they say that looks nice on
you I always say thank you but what if
they're just say like I like your shirt
I didn't make this shirt I just bought
it
are they complimenting me on purchasing
a cute shirt should I respond with I
think so too
though it seems self contrat though it
seems self congratulatory I've been
pondering this for years
can you help Alison I can can you John
ah no so I guess I'm gonna count on you
for this one
the only thing I it's so nice to have
been alive for 36 years so that I can
have answers when people do what I
consider to be a bit blooney things like
this you say I got it at the gap you
that's that's what you say like it's
it's a little bit like if somebody is
like oh that like how's how's your pasta
oh no no I strongly disagree I strong
like if somebody says to me oh I like
your suit the correct answer is not I
got it at Burberry that is wrong I think
that's what they're asking they're at
it's a way of asking like where did you
know they're not there say they're
trying to make polite conversation and
you are inserting a brand into a
conversation that needs a man I think
like
that is the only thing I've figured out
what to say when somebody says I like
your shirt I say or I say like my wife
got it for me I'd like tell the story of
the shirt and because I because there's
nothing else to say what else is there
to say you could say thank you I think
you can just say thank you because they
are ultimately complimenting you on
doing a nice job of picking out a shirt
for today I do yes I guess that's
correct and and even like the bold
fashion choices you have made like look
at that look at that contrast II plaid
you have chosen for your cute shirt you
know what I actually find Hank I find
that in general when I tell people that
I like their shirt or or that I like
their dress or or or that I like their
suit what I actually mean is unlike the
vast majority of times I notice your
shirt I was aware that it existed
whereas usually I don't actually like it
like in all probability I think that
it's a little over the top but I did
notice and so I kind of have to say
something because it's what I'm thinking
about right now right exactly so is it a
bad sign if somebody says that they like
your shirt should you'd retire that
shirt I think you might have to say I'm
sorry I'm sorry that I distract I'm
sorry I'm sorry that I forced you to
notice my shirt that was not nice of me
I think you're right I think we came to
a really good conclusion on this one
Allison stop stop wearing that shirt oh
god I'm so glad we were able to wrap
that one up quickly so basically any
time somebody gives you a compliment
just respond by saying I'm sorry okay
our next question comes from Tyler Tyler
writes Dear John and Hank I'm an atheist
and recently I've become a bit
frustrated at something concerning
English I'm finding that there's no good
secular alternative to saying I'm
praying for you in English this came up
when a friend of mine was having a lot
of anxiety issues I don't want to tell
them I'd be praying for them since I'd
be lying yet for some reason I'm always
unsatisfied with saying I hope things
get better as that just doesn't seem to
have the same weight now is there a
better alternative that I'm not thinking
of or am I just overthinking this whole
thing memento mori Tyler so Hank you and
I will have very different answers for
this question but I do not think that
you have to believe in God to pray for
someone or to pray
so that's my answer well yes so so do
you have to think that the prayer does
anything for it to be a prayer oh I
think yeah probably probably but I yeah
I guess so
cuz that's like that's the thing that
you like it's not like a linguistic
problem it's a practical problem where
there's like I'm jealous of mmm of the
phrase I'm praying for you and I am
incapable of using it honestly because I
like because it like I'm praying for you
indicates like I am NOT just thinking
about you I'm trying to do something for
you I'm trying to have like have an
effect on this situation with like
through my understanding of the universe
and how it works and and like so so I
can say you're in my thoughts or like
I've been thinking about you a lot or
you know like you've been on my mind
like that kind of thing is sort of the
secular equivalent like you'll like
these people are in our in our thoughts
and and you just leave out the prayers
part of in our thoughts and prayers so
yeah I I it's not a it's not a
linguistic problem it's a practical
problem that you don't think that you
can have a thought that will affect the
ultimate outcome but in just in saying
that you are trying to have an effect
you kind of are and so it's kind of it's
kind of a shame that we don't we don't
have a thing that we can say that feels
honest well I think I think thinking of
you does feel honest and maybe does
maybe does help I think maybe it does
help but yeah I I hear you on this being
a challenge and one that frankly I'm
very glad not to have yeah how about we
answered this question from Ryan Hank
III want to answer this question from
Ryan mostly because he literally sent in
an image of his driver's license to
prove that he is a Ryan I mean is it
worth it is it I think it's a good
question oh it yeah it is it's a great
question I'm really interested in this
question it's a hard one
oh it's from he says dear green brothers
in fact he says dear brothers green I'm
a 26 year old military vet who lives in
Charlotte County Florida which happens
to be one of the most conservative and
the oldest by meatiest median age places
in the country despite my surroundings I
consider myself deeply liberal I've
tried to make friends with neighbors and
people in my community but it is
becoming unbelievably hard
most are five decades my senior or prone
to saying things that are homophobic
racist or Islamophobic I'm fully aware
that most conservatives don't hold these
views but I unfortunately live in an
area where it is a little too common
because of all these factors I do most
of my socializing on the Internet but I
feel that I'm missing out on an aspect
of life not having any real-life friends
any dubious advice would improve my
situation and a dubious advice that
would improve my situation would be
greatly appreciated I have to say Ryan I
have spent time in Charlotte County
Florida quite a lot and I agree with you
it is an old conservative place it's
where where my my in-laws live and oh my
oh my it is not full of a lot of young
military veterans who sign off their
emails honor courage commitment you
forgot the great sign off that's a good
one it's good you're right I think it's
difficult any time you feel like there's
nobody like you in your real life
community and that's a feeling that you
know I knew very well when I was young
and that I feel kind of lucky to not
feel now but I would say that just
because there are a lot of old people in
Charlotte County Florida it does not
mean that there are no young people in
fact there are lots of young people I
and I look like when I go I'm amazed
that I see like high schools I'm like
who is having children in this town
there's their people there are people
who are young people who have elementary
school-aged children and I have no idea
where they came from because when I walk
around the town I do not see those
people but they are there so the
question is how do you meet them yeah
well they mostly work in in at the
hospital in one way or another you know
they work and they work in the care of
the people who are the sort of weirdly
enough the the industry of the town
so you just have to go Ryan you got to
go become a nurse found it or just like
her nurse I always say I'm sorry when
people compliment your clothes and
become a nurse
yeah just like stub your toe real bad
and like go into urgent care and like
look around and be like anybody want to
be my friend that is a much better idea
why become a nurse when you could just
become a patient so much easier all
right Ryan stub your toe go to Urgent
Care nobody will think that's weird
be like I'll my toe does anyone want to
be my friend they're so used to like
drug-seeking patients but you'll be that
rare patient who's just friends seeking
I do find it weird when I like see my
doctor in real life and I'm like hey oh
I just saw my psychiatrist in real life
Hank oh yeah yeah it was incredibly
uncomfortable thank God he didn't
actually see me because I dove under the
table I was having a drink with my
beautiful wife on date night and who do
I see striding up at it at a pretty good
clip and by the way if my psychiatrist
is listening to the pod I don't know how
involved he is in my private life but
you know please just like pause for 30
seconds but uh yeah I mean who do I see
striding up and I was like Sarah Sarah
that's dr. Patel and she was like who
and I was like dr. Patel and she was
like go say hi and I was like say hi no
no this is yeah we are we are having a
crisis this is an emergency
yeah I did what did you become okay yeah
well he ended up having a drink in the
same restaurant so I just like turned my
chair so that he couldn't see me yeah I
was fine everything chilled out after
that long story short Ryan get a
psychiatrist and go out to bars and try
to run across your I don't think that
we're doing a good job of answering this
question it is really hard to make
friends in adulthood like I still don't
really know how to do it Ryan and I
think part of what's difficult about the
time of your life is not just where you
live or the kind of people you live near
but also that it's just kind of a hard
time in life yeah it
I mean I like finding it's it's weird
because it's like well let's just find
the places where people like you are
going but it's like well if people like
me we're going to places I would be the
people who go to those places those
places that exist like in the town where
my in-laws live there isn't a movie
theater like there isn't there isn't
places to go do things there are like
the weird Beach bars that I don't think
are necessarily Ryan scene
so yeah I definitely I i commiserate
with that and and figure it like it
again it's like why isn't there tinder
for friends and it's because that's just
too like it's too much it's too weird
you know it has to be natural and it's
it's very hard to find natural ways to
define folks that's outside of I think
for the record there are some there are
tenders for friends and people do use
them but Hank and I are so far outside
that world that we are not going to be
able to advise you on them I have no
idea how you call someone through tinder
I assume that there is some kind of like
tender call functionality but I'm not
I'm not hip and with-it into him back in
that world all right I think we have
another question this one comes from
Joseph who writes Dear John and Hank I
was looking at clothes on the internet
and my mother told me expensive doesn't
mean better and I was wondering if you
agree because I haven't heard fashion
advice on the pod yet and you're both
fashion icons thank you for noticing
Joseph is it $3 and 97 sent from Walmart
as good as a $145 grey t-shirt from
Ralph Lauren Purple Label I didn't even
know that Ralph Warren had a purple
label this is incredibly exciting news
for me I don't understand the extra
expense should I spend more money
buttons and threads Joseph now Hank and
I are going to have very different
answers here because Hank continues to
shop for his clothing primarily
secondhand that's not true I do both
that's why I said primarily Joseph there
are some people in the world who are not
able to enjoy the finer things in life
like my brother you know and and you put
him in one t-shirt and it's as good as
any other t-shirt because to him it's
just the pleasure of not being naked and
warm that's all he cares about
but people like us Joseph we understand
that when you pay a hundred and
forty-five dollars for a gray t-shirt it
is a really good t-shirt
no I'm just kidding never pay more than
twenty two dollars plus shipping for
your t-shirts at dftba.com available
artists dftba.com there's no other place
to get t-shirts on the internet that's
even worth pursuing
- Joseph I say first of all you haven't
heard fashion advice on the pod we just
gave some so apparently this is fashion
day
second there is a difference between a
$4 to certain a hundred and fifty dollar
t-shirts and the thing is there's a that
there's definitely more value it's just
that there's not a hundred and forty
dollars more value like that's that's
the weird thing about like luxury
products is like you keep making it
better until like your for every like
like increment of better you are getting
the prices going way way out of
proportion
to the increment of betterness and it's
almost like and I've noticed this about
people who have the opportunity to to do
this that people start to become experts
on excellence and so they can tell the
difference between a hundred dollar
t-shirt and a hundred and fifty dollar
t-shirt in a way that to me or indeed
any one else except for like you know
the five thousand people who buy
t-shirts like this would is just
completely obtuse and makes no sense but
there is a difference and there's lots
of differences when it comes to like I
mean I've run a merch company so like
there's softness and but there's also
things like was the cotton sustainably
raised well like are the factories
factories where people are treated well
was it made in America or was it made in
like a place where there isn't a lot of
oversight and so like there are
differences and but but but that's not
the difference between a $25 shirt and
$150 t-shirt you can get a $25 t-shirt
that was made in the US with sustainably
produced cotton
when you're paying $150 for t-shirt
you're paying $150 for a luxury
experience that and I totally agree with
you Hank there's this Sarah and I always
talk about this great line that Ira
Glass the host of this American life had
after he moved to New York
he said it's three times as expensive
but only twice as fun
yeah that's definitely the that's
definitely the t-shirt experience that
t-shirt is 10 times as expensive and
only like one point three times better
right it's the same thing with red wine
or stereo equipment or any number of
things that you can get really really
into if you want to devote a lot of your
resources to it
yeah but I agree with Hank that when you
stop noticing the difference in quality
and when it stops being material to your
quality of life you should stop trying
yeah to don't and she ate yeah don't try
to figure out why something is better
don't like dedicate your time to
figuring out why she should be spending
more money on something definitely live
in that ignorant for as long as you can
yeah I agree Hank why don't I let you
ask a question yeah that's nice thank
you this one is from Natalie who asks
dear Hank and John I have a problem this
morning I bought a bag of popcorn for
exactly $2.99 I paid in cash so I was
expecting to receive a penny however of
course I find pennies useless I was
planning in advance to place that penny
in the donations box next to the
register the problem is the cashier did
not give me my penny she didn't even ask
if I wanted the change she simply said
have a nice day
and closed the register I didn't know
what to say so I just walked away
penniless I mean that's not that I feel
like that's the literal definition of
penniless but not not really what we
mean when we say that I don't know how
to feel about this I didn't particularly
want the penny but I also feel like I
was owed the penny did this shop just
steal from me and by extension from
charity should I be upset that I was not
giving the money or should I just go on
with life since pennies are so useless
anyway Ave OTT que valet
Natalie it says hey it's hail and
farewell in Latin that's good goods from
an elegant poem by the Roman poet
catalyst oh good good yeah uh addressed
to catalyst his dead brother or strictly
speaking to the ashes of catalysis dawg
yes yes I guess that makes sense this
happens to me frequently John has this
happened to you it has and I do not
believe that stores are nd under any
obligation to carry any pennies so it
may be that they are refusing to engage
with the penny as currency yeah I mean
fret like I think that this cashier
might have thought that they were doing
you a favor because who wants a freaking
penny I like technically the cashier
should give you the penny and the
cashiers probably trained to give you
the penny in fact they there sometimes
there's like inventory that goes on and
they count the change in the cash
register and it's not right then they
can get in trouble and but probably that
not at that place if this person is so
blase about pennies but yeah I I almost
consider it a personal favor to not have
to even think about the fact that the
penny ever existed yeah yeah I mean I
would see this as a gift to you rather
than taking a penny away from charity
because PS that charity doesn't need a
penny
it needs a dime or more yeah yeah yeah
yep I'll go read all right Hank let's
answer another question this one comes
from Ian who writes hello Green brothers
especially since the most recent
election I found it harder to find an
independent news source I often read
through various subreddits that seem to
be unbiased but also try to balance that
with reading subreddits populated by the
left or the right and I also watched
Philip DeFranco daily because I feel
like he filters out a lot of stuff
purely through research and
cross-checking how should I get my news
without spending hours doing research
and cross-checking I want to make sure I
consider all sides without fail at fault
without following for fake news or
unsubstantiated stories no interesting
sign-off Ian yeah so I've been doing an
experiment the last few weeks where I
read my local hometown newspaper The
Indianapolis Star and The Wall Street
Journal in The New York Times and The
Economist as well as The New Yorker and
it gives me a wide variety of news
stories I think
of what people cite as biased comes from
the opinion pages of those newspapers
which are a really small portion of what
they do like I think sometimes their
reporting is wrong or it's incomplete
but I don't think that it's consistently
biased like I think if you read the New
York Times or The Wall Street Journal or
The Economist's coverage of Brazil or
South Korea you won't find it to be
consistently biased and I think the same
is mostly true of their us coverage I
think so I I am a big believer in
newspapers and news organizations when
it comes to the actual gathering of news
and the reporting of news I think
newspapers and news organizations that
are well established do a better job of
that than anyone else at the moment I
think when it comes to news analysis
which is a different thing and most of
what Phil does is I think ultimately
news analysis telling you kind of why
the news matters or what's what's
important about it
I think traditional news companies don't
do as good of a job although I think
there are very good opinion columns at
times in all of those newspapers and
magazines and in many others but I think
that's what the internet is good at is
news analysis but I don't think it's I
think the old wine media companies are
still pretty good at news gathering and
news reporting yeah I think there's a
very important distinction there a lot
of what you see on the Internet is sort
of like what's the scandal of the day
and what is that what what's might what
should my take be what are some good
takes on this scandal of the day and
that and the scandals are always things
that have really sharply defined sides
and a and and like but but maybe aren't
the most like like they they often
haven't been all the way worked out
there like stories in progress and so
the people are having opinions about
things that haven't been all the way
understood yet and so these like like
tremenda like these big stories that
that are in the in progress of coming
out
everybody's gonna have lots of opinions
about them and and and it can it's much
easier to have your opinion be
influenced by sort of like what you
would like the world to be like and and
and a lot of what you see on the
internet and also like with things like
The Daily Show is we're talking about
how the news is covering the news not
about the news itself and the news
becomes the rose the media be cut like
you're covering the media rather than
covering what the media is covering and
like what like the actual covering like
the actual journalism stuff is hard and
people like me and you Phil DeFranco
don't do that and like The Daily Show
also for the most part doesn't do that
and if we just like spend all our time
ragging on them The Times they get it
wrong and talking about how like these
people are completely useless and don't
do any good stuff because I can find
these two examples of how they screwed
up stories in the last year it's like
well but you're not trying to do that no
one else is trying to do it you're just
going after them when they get it wrong
very occasionally when the vast majority
of the reporting that gets done is good
journalism even like across the board
like when you're talking about a more
conservative paper like The Wall Street
Journal or a more liberal paper like the
New York Times
like like the Wall Street Journal is I'm
gonna talk about global warming all the
time but like you will find that like
the the journalism that gets done there
for the most part overlaps like the
people like the stories that are getting
done like they agree with each other and
but like but those those don't get
sucked into the outrage cycle because
there's a Gris right that's what I would
highlight is that there's a lot that
goes in I think to being an informed
person that the outrage cycle leaves out
because it's either a very complicated
story or because it's a story on which a
lot of people agree so if you look at
the news right now for instance you know
that we're not seeing a ton of reporting
about Somalia even though there's a
famine there we're not seeing a ton of
reporting on the internet anyway about
these huge corruption scandals that are
ongoing in in Brazil and now reaching
outside of Brazil
and we're not you know and we're not
seeing a ton of like coverage on the
internet about many other international
stories but also national stories i
highlighted this in a video i made
recently but you know we're not talking
that much about the Federal Reserve's
monetary policy even though it has huge
implications for all of us because it's
not a story that's easy to get outraged
about it's not a story that's easy to
take sides on and so I think on those
stories which I I would argue are
actually like the bulk of stories when
it comes to being an informed person I
think the news media does a relatively
good job and I also think that like
local for me my local newspaper does a
really good job keeping me informed
about issues that are really relevant in
some ways more relevant to my life
because they are local issues when it
comes to the laws and regulations and
leaders that affect my city and my state
that's that's really important to my
day-to-day life in a way that some of
the larger conversations aren't so I
agree with you and I think we have to we
have to call the media out when they do
a bad job of reporting but we also need
to celebrate when they do a good job
yeah and and when you sit down with the
newspaper and you read the stories
you're like oh this was this was
actually interesting and useful and I
had no idea that it existed which is it
also becomes in a way less scary like I
find the news to be really overwhelming
and scary a lot of times right now and I
feel like what the heck is happening
like this and and and a lot of it is
true like we are not living in normal
times in the United States
politically or socially and it's
important to acknowledge that and it's
important to be honest about that but at
the same time when I read stories
carefully reported stories and
newspapers I realize that you know we've
always been living in strange times or
at least we've often had been living in
strange times yeah I agree I agree I
would like to ask a question that I
would like to answer John okay but you
can also try to answer it if you want
it's from Stella who asks dear Hank and
John I'm sorry if my English is horrible
but I'll try my best so I was wondering
if there was any difference in organ or
other
things inside our bodies size and shape
between the tallest person in the world
in the shortest person in the world I
mean like do tall people's hearts and
lungs are they like longer or the
difference is just in the arrangement of
the organs are tall people's insides
more spacious and short people's insides
denser organs and body parts Estela yeah
I mean I I don't know bodies are amazing
like the the fact that you can have a
seven-foot tall person and like and and
like a four foot tall person or you know
like that the the the differences in
sizes of human bodies and even like
crazier with dogs and stuff like these
are the same species but like there's
Chihuahuas and there's Great Danes like
that the body figures out how to make
itself proportional no matter what size
you are and we're not entirely sure how
that works there's a lot of different
stuff that goes into it but yes bigger
people have bigger organs smaller people
have smaller organs otherwise it would
not fit inside and that would be a
tremendous problem and also yeah there's
no like empty spaces inside of tall
people which is that's good
I'm glad about that it'd be real weird
but it's pretty cool I kind of want
there to be an empty space inside of me
sometimes I feel like you know everybody
has that feeling sometimes like there's
an empty space inside of them that
nothing can fill yeah and it would be
nice if that were literally true if I
could be like oh yeah it's that it's
that part between my lungs and my
diaphragm ah that's where the emptiness
is yeah nope you're pretty packed a
solid in there John we are all pretty
packed solid it's kind of remarkable me
but you don't really want to look unless
unless you're like you know doctorin but
uh it's pretty cool pretty cool if one
of my central ambitions is never to see
the inside of my abdominal cavity it's
good it's a good one to have Hank we
need to get on to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon so that we can get to the
all-important Ryan part of the podcast
great agree we've got to get to this
weekend Ryan which again you can get
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
can sign up a new level and you can
weekly Ryan podcast but let's get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon and
let's just start with the news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank because it's awesome oh
good it's awesome so uh Hank on March
14th you don't come to a dear Hank and
John for necessarily up-to-date AFC
Wimbledon news on March 14th AFC
Wimbledon welcomed two Kingsmeadow the
franchise currently applying its trade
in Milton Keynes it was a difficult and
complex and emotionally exhausting thing
to do to have to welcome the team that
used to be they are at least fancies
themselves you the team that used to be
you and throughout the game AFC
Wimbledon fans saying one of my all-time
favorite songs where were you where were
you where were you when you were us and
for the first time in league 1 AFC
Wimbledon defeated the Milton Keynes
team to nil beautiful game really I
listened to the whole thing on Radio W
do n because it was not on TV and oh man
oh gosh it felt good I would like to say
that I didn't care about the result
because Wimbledon had already won by
getting back to Ligue 1 but actually I
did I did care about the result and it
was oh it felt good oh god it felt good
good job I'm excited for you so even
more important finally happened is that
that's the first time that's happened
right it's the first time that it's
happened in a league competition they
lost okay they lost earlier so it was
wild Taylor the Messi for Montserrat who
scored the second goal and helpfully I
just want to give a quick shout-out to
Lyle Taylor because he was kind enough
to celebrate right in front of our
advertising hoardings
that says the nerdfighter community is
helping AFC wimbledon get at wimbledon
and so that picture is in all of the was
in all of the newspapers in london so
thank you Lisle Taylor for out
celebrating in front of our advertising
I know that you did that on purpose and
I appreciate it uh
that is that is the dopest job also I
should add one more thing since then AFC
Wimbledon has drawn a game nil nil and
critically that means that with 38 games
played with 8 games left in the league
one season
AFC Wimbledon are on 51 points meaning
that they are only one point from
absolute definite safety
so if Wimbledon just win or tie one of
their last eight games they will almost
definitely not get relegated so that's
great
woohoo what's the news from Mars well I
guess the news from Mars is that
President Trump signed a bill funding
NASA it's a it's kind of strange like
it's not part of the budget it's just
sort of like it's like it was a
bipartisan support thing that's like
here NASA you're gonna get funded and it
didn't have any of the cuts to the earth
science departments that was in Trump's
larger budget which is good news cuz
like it's good for NASA to study the
earth because of how you know as Leon
must we'll tell you it's a pretty good
planet and we need to try and keep it
that way yep but part of that was was
helping to get nasa's big hunk of cash
to help us get to mars Elon Musk on the
other hand the actual Elon Musk
is not a fan of the veil he says this
bill changes almost nothing about what
NASA is doing existing programs stay in
place and there is to be clear no added
funding for Mars and it was sort of like
pitched as like this is gonna be the
Mars thing but you yuan later tweeted
perhaps there will be some future bill
that makes a difference for Mars but
this is not it well I'm glad that nASA
has funding though because I do think
that of the things that our government
does NASA is probably the most beautiful
it is pretty awesome it's pretty awesome
followed closely by the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting which partly funds
the art assignment and crash course also
very awesome also very awesome thanks
well Hank thank you for potting with me
but before we go it's time for our
brand-new podcast this week in riot
this week in Bryans were fighting over
who gets to say it I think it's good
gotta be me right you you you're you're
not that you're like sort of like the
peripheral character if you're Hank and
John so it should probably be me right
this weekend Ryan's alright John who is
the Ryan this week well Hank were
starting out with the most famous Ryan
in the world according to rancor calm
which whisks does R anchored wait rancor
ranks people by first name Hank rancors
slogan is vote on everything including
apparently your favorite Ryan's so the
the most famous Ryan in the world
according to rancor comm is Ryan Gosling
that does not surprise me I test that is
what I would have said now I'm very
curious I'm curious who the most famous
Hank is John I have a weird name I have
a weird name I'm probably I'm probably
in the top five the most famous Hank by
far is Hank Williams yes I think Hank
Azaria may also be could be hank it
could it could be Hank Aaron behind care
and also Hank Hill who is not real but
still put me real quick go to rancor
calm and tell you the most famous Hanks
in the world number one Hank Azaria I
don't know that this is a very good
website is pretty famous he was married
to Helen Hunt
Hank I've got some bad news yes
according to rancor calm you are
actually the 21st most famous you're
behind Hank Brown who is a former US
senator from Colorado you're not even
the most famous Hank with a color last
name that would be Hank Brown or
possibly if you consider snow to be a
color Hank Snow who is a celebrated
Canadian country music artist oh well
John before before we go down this
rabbit hole any further what do we do
about Ryan Gosling yeah Ryan Gosling of
course famous for his recent role in
la-la-land
but most famous for having a face that I
love to look at can i just Google and
coming to Google
mmm-hmm if I just google Ryan abs I'm
not gonna put his last name in I'm gonna
see uh yeah that's a great I just ride
who's the first Ryan's ABS that I say oh
it's Ryan lucky
it's Ryan Lochte it's not even Ryan
Gosling he's gonna be the star of a
future episode of this week in Ryan's I
am looking at Ryan Gosling's ABS now
though and I'm I'm not disappointed but
moving on because of course Ryan Gosling
is not only a beautiful face and an
astonishingly fit pair of ABS just do
them the only one of the little known
facts about Ryan Gosling is that he only
has two abdominal muscle man Hank do you
know what Ryan Gosling is from uh is he
from Canada because he's a goose a small
yes he is from Canada he is a Canadian
actor and musician and you know how he
got a start he got a start on the Mickey
Mouse Club
oh I thought that was an American thing
he was also on goosebumps he was on
goosebumps and his last name is goose
his last name is tiny goose and he was
on goosebumps oh my goodness it he's
from Canada where the geese come it is
amazing his uh his his dad Thomas Ray
Gosling was a traveling salesman for a
paper mill and his mom was a secretary
and and is now a high school teacher and
one thing that you might not know about
Bryan's great-great grandfather George
Edward Gosling is that he was English
that's not interesting hold on let me
find something interesting
well IMDB will tell you that the movies
that they are most known for which I
also always find interesting I would
have thought that la-la-land would be
number one but they have drive then
lollol and then the big short then Crazy
Stupid Love III also want to know the
movies he's least known for but probably
it's goosebumps and the Mickey Mouse
Club yeah I don't know I mean I I feel
like I saw him in the Mickey Mouse Club
a few tons but then I do have small
children and at this point we are very
far down the Mickey Mouse rabbit hole
his first ever role was in 1995
the TV series are you afraid of the dark
which I was probably watching in 1995 as
Jamie Leary and Jamie leery you can
click on that because apparently it's a
clickable thing and does not I've got a
quote from Jamie Lee leery
he says that's my brother he's not dead
what I don't know if that's the quote
that they they pulled out of the episode
Jamie leery said that I don't know why
we're gonna have to watch it John it's
that episode are you afraid of the dark
from 1995 called the tale of station 109
point one it's a haunted radio station I
think do you know what Ryan Gosling's
childhood nickname was uh well his
current nickname is Ryan
mini goose Gosling that's right but
we're just we are only coining that now
so obviously that wasn't his childhood
nickname because when people look back
on history and at some point like I
think Ryan Gosling will probably stop
like being Ryan in in the movies and
it'll just say you know starring Eva
Mendes and Minnie goose Gosselin his
childhood nickname was trouble
Ryan trouble Gosling when I look into
his eyes I can see that he might be a
person whose childhood nickname was
trouble well in first grade
having been heavily influenced by the
action film first blood he took steak
knives to school and threw them and
other children during recess which led
to his suspension that is a bad idea rut
don't you that is bad bad don't put that
in your auto body Hey are you at all
familiar with the singer-songwriter Ryan
Cabrera
uh well John I feel like he's off limits
he's not off limits because wait for it
Ryan Cabrera noted singer-songwriter has
a tattoo on his calf of Ryan Gosling Wow
Ryan ception I'm looking at it right now
it's Ryan ception Ryan Gosling also has
tattoos of one of them he said one of my
tattoos is supposed to be a monsters
hand dropping a bloody heart but I did
it myself with the tattoo kit so it
looks like a cactus
oh man and I'm looking at the tattoo
right now and I mean it's not good
how can Ryan Gosling be so hot and so
bad at getting tattoos I mean this is
the worst tattoo I've ever seen I mean
it will put it up on the patreon but oh
my god
this is the worst tattoo I have ever
seen in my entire life
it looks like Beavis from beavis and
butt-head had a baby with a cactus that
then spit out a heart I'm looking
forward to seeing the picture of this
John I googled Ryan Gosling tattoo and I
just got a lot of tattoos of Ryan
Gosling not Ryan Gosling's tattoos
number of them including this one which
is a tattoo of Ryan Gosling's face
superimposed on a spider and it says
Ryan Gosling it's really good I like it
a lot actually I'm gonna save that one
for the patreon as well well this this
John has been this week in Ryan's we've
started out with the most both start out
with the most famous Ryan of all the
Ryan's Ryan Gosling at least for now and
he's you know that Justin Timberlake's
mom was Ryan Gosling's legal guardian
for six months what what did you know
that Ryan Gosling called AJ McClain in
the early 1990s to ask if he could join
the Backstreet Boys Wow I mean did you
know that there's a person who has a
tattoo of Ryan Gosling except instead of
Ryan Gosling's beard it's a pepperoni
pizza save that one for the for the bay
tree you know that Ryan Gosling is in a
band called dead men's bones that only
sing songs about paranormal phenomena
Wow
no that's wonderful I like Ryan Gosling
much more now than I did at the
beginning of this this this weekend Ryan
I think at the end of each episode of
this weekend Ryan Hank we should just
pause and real quickly give a grade
rating right right we should we should
Ryan that we have spent the last five to
ten min
meeting and I give ryan gosling based on
my quick read of his Wikipedia page and
some trivia an a-minus no John we cannot
just give them grades we have to give
them a thing out of a thing like now our
like again I grade Ryan Gosling 62
Minnie gooses it shouldn't it be a
consistent rating system though so the
Ryan's the world can know whether or not
they stack up against other Ryan's
definitely not no no we are not here to
make the Ryan's feel bad though we're
here to make Ryan's feel good mostly I
would think unless there's a tab sure
there's terrible Ryan's out there at
some point we're gonna get to Ryan's Rex
Ryan I don't know that's I think that's
lovely
point being we've got it we've got to
think of a rating system but we haven't
thought of one so we'll do that by next
time because I have to go pick up my kid
now okay well this has been once again
this week is Ryan Ryan and I are really
competing to try to be the voice of this
weekend Ryan I like that I like that
should be a thing John
what did we learn today really well we
learned that Ryan Gosling is the most
famous Ryan in the world and Hank green
is the 21st most famous Hank we also
learned that if someone compliments you
on your shirt you really just you need
to apologize for your shirt you've made
a horrible mistake horrible mistake and
of course we learned that this week's
podcast for some reason didn't have the
usual fake sponsors that we have nope no
fake sponsors because it's brought to
you by one Ryan's and to you our patreon
patrons and also the just of people who
listen who aren't patreon patrons which
is also to be clear fine yes we're
grateful to all of you and lastly we
learned that you can pay ten times more
for a shirt but it will only be about
1.1 times better than the cheap one
that's him it depends on the exact
context but I broadly agree with you
thank you for potting with me Hank
thanks to everybody for listening dear
Hank and John is produced by rosianna
halse rojas and sheridan gifts in our
editor is Nicholas Jenkins Victoria
buongiorno is our head of community and
communications our music is by the great
gunnarolla you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com you can find Hank on
Twitter at Hank green it's hard to find
me on Twitter these days except at
sports with John and Allie on must
number for Earth thanks again for
listening and as we say in my hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]